quatre jours après avoir envahi le
palais présidentiel
les bureaux du premier ministre sont
pris d'assaut par des manifestants le
président gotabaya rajapaksa est en
fuite il a désigné son premier ministre
ranil wickremesinghe et comme président
par intérim il est encore trop proche du
clan rajapaksa la colère persiste plus
aux jo sri-lankais nous sommes des
citoyens du sri lanka nous sommes ici
pour sauver notre pays dit cet homme le
pays de 22 millions d'habitants est au
bord de l'implosion fortement endetté le
gouvernement n'a plus de devises
étrangères pour importer les produits de
base comme le pétrole il y à une
faillite de l'état et le les tablettes
sont vides les produits de consommation
sont plus distribués les transports
publics ne fonctionnent plus les toc toc
les voitures les rives et les camions
tout se sait mort
accusé de corruption et de népotisme
rajapaksa est le dernier du clan qui
aura dominé la politique sri lankaise
depuis deux décennies
son mode de vie même si le président du
parlement assure que rajapaksa
démissionnera rien n'a été confirmé
le politicien déchu a plutôt donné le
mandat au président par intérim de
rétablir la loi et l'ordre pour la
constitution ne lui permet pas comme
président de pouvoir quitter son
fauteuil est nommé lui-même un nouveau
président
au même moment à montréal la diaspora
sri-lankaise célèbre la déesse durga
avec l'inquiétude comme trame de fond
des lots noël et oui comme next ils ne
savent pas là bas lorsqu'il se lève
s'ils vont avoir de l'eau s'ils vont
avoir de l'électricité
dix-sept jeunes montréalaises d'origine
sri lankaise
l'eau sacrée purifie les fidèles comme
une métaphore de la purge politique dans
leur pays d'origine la magie du genre de
tous contents que ça arrive parce que
c'était dur mais c'est pas les bras on
en est pas de la fin une feinte
imprévisible un couvre-feu a été imposé
dans tout le pays
l'armée sri lankaise appel à une
résolution politique l'élection d'un
nouveau chef d'état est prévue le 20
juillet ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal